[Music]  was my family three years ago they would  kill I have nothing that I'm finding  people who did this will kill every last  one of them I need your help  stop don't panic  be calm be still shoot me what right  here we gotta get you rhythm section  under control you give your heart as the  drums your breathing to the base that's  the easy part  what's the hard part living with it  we're gonna have to be some enough  let's come  I'm gonna do this my way a lot of people  think that you're dead I got a lot  give your heart is the Trump's your  breathing is the base we're gonna get  you in a fight  we take too long how long the menopause  will be a distant memory it's a good  stuff  [Music]